[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avez vous déjà mais votre index dans la
paume d'un nouveau-né et regarder ses
doigts qui s'enroule autour c'est
vraiment un phénomène trop chaud on se
dit ouah ce bébé y même bien lien qui se
crée un rattachement qui se forme et
bien cela fait partie des réflexes
développementaux comptes ou les bébés
notamment le réflexe d'hagrid mans donc
la mauvaise nouvelle de cette soirée
c'est que ce n'est pas par préférence
forcément que le dd savez pas vous il le
vrai pour n'importe qui n'importe quand
car c'est un réflexe
désolé mais ce qui est intéressant par
contre c'est le lien qui a entre les
mains et la bouche à stage là donc on
verra peut-être que quand l'enfant est
en train de téter il ya des petits
mouvements qui se font simultanément
mais ça on n'y reviendra plus tard pour
l'instant c'est quoi un réflexe c'est un
mouvement automatique ou in et chorales
enfants et ce mouvement est ce qui
aidera au développement de l'enfant
d'ailleurs ce réflexe d'un rythme en ce
n'est pas le premier qu'il aura eu mais
il aura déjà eu toute une série d'un
reflex dans l'utérus nommé intra utérin
et par la suite il aura cantine est
jusqu'à l'âge de trois ans et demi
environ
des réflexes de durée variable après
cela à trois ans et demi les réflexes
posturaux vont venir remplacer les
réflexes archaïques et rester à vie
maintenant vous dire eh bah c'est bien
ce histoire de réflexes et si mignon les
doigts qui s'enroule autour du tien mais
dans la vie de tous les jours
concrètement ça change quoi en fait
et bien c'est une très très bonne
question et il s'avère qu'à mon avis ça
change beaucoup
reprenons ce même des béquilles avait ce
réflexe d'agde rythme en ont le on
appellera crois mais il se débat
bon non gagnants et voilà on avance de 4
à 6 mois en mai dans sa chaise haute et
on veut lui donner le biberon voilà
quand même en l'occurrence il est
asiatique oui donc on le mettra dans sa
chaise haute vous alors vas-y toi mais
tu bois faut boire pour devenir grand
voire du lait vous devenir grand et fort
kwame mais chromé et du lait partout
quand je vais faire pour nettoyer tout
ça bon tu te reprends tes quand même un
gentil petit garçon ou tu tu te prends
croire oui donc on a fait tous été dans
cette situation où on donne à manger à
l'enfant et il s'amuse à acheter tout ce
qui lui passe par léman par terre et aux
e-bike un peu insupportable mais faut se
rappeler d'une chose c'est qu'il ya six
mois
le tic aux amis il avait un réflexe
d'agrément tellement fort qu'on pouvait
le soulever tellement ils s'attachaient
il ne lâchait plus rien et là six mois
plus tard il fait une découverte énorme
c'est qui peut lâcher prise
littéralement et ça peut nous sembler
banal à vous et moi
en fait c'est énorme c'est vraiment un
accomplissement donc la bonne nouvelle
de ce soir c'est qu'à l'âge de 6 mois
environ
le bébé et pour acheter tout ce qu'il
veut par terre et le faire exprès en
plus un non non
non mais sérieusement si ça vous fait
pas savouré j'suis pas la solution voulu
donner à voir vous même nom vous ça vous
fait peut-être pas très tellement rire
le fait qu'ils puissent jeter tout ce
qu'il veut par terre mais vous aurez
peut-être tort car figurez vous qu'un
jour ça ne sera plus vaudois ho kelly
s'agrippera ni même en biberons mais ça
sera un stylo qui devra tenir ou un
ciseau qui devra utiliser et là s'il
n'arrive plus à lâcher problème trouvera
peut-être ça par exemple ou bien manque
de dextérité des problèmes dans sa
motricité fine ou bien vu le lien qu'on
a vues entre les mains et la bouche un
problème dans le développement de son
langage et là on peut se demander
comment ça se fait qu'il ya des enfants
chez qui ces réflexes ont retenu et
d'autres chez qu'ils ne sont pas ça fait
une cinquantaine d'années environ
qu'on essaie de répondre à cette
question est en tout cas ce qui est
clair c'est que chez les enfants qui ont
des difficultés d'apprentissage
il y a un lien très fort entre leurs
capacités académique et les réflexes qui
ont été retenus
donc les chercheurs regarderont le
développement normal d'un enfant et
regarderont ils verront que les réflexes
suivent des stages assez constant à
travers les enfants
donc si on reprend le petit coin mais à
six mois qu'est ce qu'il est en train de
faire simultanément il apprend à marcher
à quatre pattes et à moins que le petit
quoi me soit en gorille il ne pourra pas
marcher à quatre pattes les poings
fermés
il sera obligé un jour d'ouvrir et là
tandis qu'avant on avait une stimulation
de la paume qui causait le réflexe
d'agrément on verra que petit à petit
cette stimulation elle se dissipe et on
voit l'inhibition d'un réflexe pour
donner place à un autre et donc fait à
partir de cette logique là que les
chercheurs se sont dit mais si c'est
dans ce milieu naturel que les reflex se
développe et se dissipe
se peut-il que les enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage n'ont pas
fait certains mouvements ou bien quand
les ans ils n'ont pas été intégrées
comme il fallait la première fois et
donc ils ont créé des programmes de
mouvements pour retourner en arrière en
quelque sorte et réintégré refaire des
mouvements qui ont été louées entre
guillemets la première fois et pour ce
faire il faut tester
quels réflexes sont présents elles et
qu'elles ne le sont pas pour le réflexe
d'un recrutement on voudra tester
quelque chose qui s'appelle la 10 10 à
deux coquines esi
qu'est ce que c'est on demandera à
l'enfant de se placer comme ça et si le
réflexe efforts ou vera jack sa série
gide parce que rappelez vous que le
réflexe d'un bris puis y'a pas de
différenciation entre les doigts et s'il
est fort ce sera un peu rigide et pour
tester on voudra qu'il fasse des
mouvements alternatifs rapide comme ceci
même si le réflexe les bacs présent ça
demande un tout petit peu de
concentration mais si le réflexe lez
orchies
j'arrive pas à le faire
c'est pas acquis en tout cas mettons ça
comme ça bon alors que faire avec toutes
ces informations vous dites d'être à ce
stade mais c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours tenu au stylo bizarrement ou
bien c'est pour ça que j'ai une écriture
atroce j'en mettrais pas ma main a coûté
car je ne suis pas en train de dire que
tous vos problèmes d'enfance sont dus à
des réflexes retenue soyons clairs
néanmois le problème qu'on a c'est le
suivant fait des casse systématique
quand le bébé né à lille ça va de soi
mais il n'existe pas de test à l'âge de
4-5 ans quand le bébé et quand l'enfant
plus tôt et ça ils s'apprêtent à aller à
l'école et qu'il lui faut regarder
regarder le tableau restait act as y
apprendra à lire à écrire à rester
organisés concentré chose que les reflex
en temps normal sont censé l'avoir aidée
et préparer à pouvoir faire car moi je
ne vous ai mentionné qu'un seul réflexe
mais il en existe toute une panoplie et
il se développe avec notre sens de la
coordination de l' équilibre avec notre
langage nos voix sensorielle notre
système physio le physio logique et même
nos émotions nouveau t-il donc pas la
peine
d'éduquer les instituteurs à au moins
pouvoir repérer ses réflexes et
peut-être à établir si oui ou non ils
seraient à l'origine de lacunes qui voit
au sein de la classe durant deux jours
en jours
cette année nous pensons à latence
d'aller trop vite dans un monde qui
s'accélère nous nous laissons trop
souvent entraînés par le mouvement
mais si justement en tant que parent
pédagogue instituteur nous ne laissions
pas assez entraînés par le mouvement de
nos enfants à travers le réflexe qui eux
nous en décret leur aptitude à apprendre
à évaluer si peut-être en tant qu'adulte
nous aurions pas nous louper un stade
primordial d'évaluation scolaire pensons
à cela pour que dans les jours qui
viennent
nos enfants puissent s'épanouir dans un
environnement pour lequel ils sont
vraiment prêts
[Applaudissements]